When the coronavirus pandemic forced
much of the world into lockdown,
it highlighted what social creatures
we humans are.
More than half of UK adults surveyed
agreed that a reduction
in social contact during lockdown
made life harder.
Social neuroscientist John Cacioppo
argued that: "loneliness
is an evolutionary signal
telling us something is not right
with your social environment,
and that you need to do
something about it, fast".
Having really good relationships
in your life
is fundamental
to your personal well-being.
And being able to reach out to people
who really care about you
is so important.
So why does maintaining
friendships and relationships
sometimes feel so hard?
We can all strengthen the
relationships we have in our lives
as well as creating quality new ones.
Here are some tips to help you
connect better with those around you.
The first one is listen.
It's all very well being interesting,
but it's equally important to be
interested in what other people
have got to say to you.
So really listening helps people
to feel more valued.
Active listening is a skill,
one we can all practise
and get better at.
When you're in a conversation,
non-verbal signs
such as eye contact, mirroring
and nodding all help create
a positive environment.
Asking questions for clarification
and paraphrasing and
reflecting back what is said
also shows that you're really trying
to understand what someone is saying.
Being an active listener
means that you recognise
the conversation is more about
the other person than about you.
Sometimes you can feel lonely even
though there are people around you.
Making sure that the time you spend
with other people is of good quality
can help combat those feelings.
Switch off the television,
play some games, cook together,
communicate, really talk to each
other, and spend that time together.
Whether we feel happy and
connected with our loved ones
may depend on the activities
we do together.
One study found that our happiness
and feelings of closeness
are more to do with
different types of activities
we do with friends
and family members
as opposed to the
relationships themselves.
One distraction that often gets in
the way is your mobile phone.
Very often we can be in
conversation with people
and we're not absolutely present.
So putting the mobile technology
away is a really good way
to create that connection.
Another skill that can help
is talking openly.
Author Susan Scott wrote:
"Never be afraid of the
conversations you're having.
Be afraid of the conversations
you're not having".
If there's things that you
feel frustrated about
and you need to get off your chest,
it's a really good idea to talk about
them rather than let them fester.
Often we might not want to talk
because we are afraid we might
upset the other person
or damage our relationship with them,
and sometimes we just don't know
how to raise an issue skilfully.
So firstly, ask yourself: "What's
really bothering me?"
You can bring it up in an open
and respectful way
with phrases like:
"I have a concern"
or: "This is how I feel when...".
Listen to the other person's thoughts
and genuinely try to understand
where they are coming from.
Asking: "I am curious
to understand why...",
or: "Why do you say this?"
can really help with that.
And don't forget to tell people
how much you care about them,
how important they are to you,
and how much you value them.
It's also important to bear in mind
that you are never going
to change anybody,
but the only person that you
can really change is yourself.
So sometimes, rather than focusing
on all the things that irritate you
about somebody, it's important
to focus on their strengths.
Another thing that can help
you really connect with others
is kindness.
Studies have found that
being kind to others
is linked to increased
feelings of happiness,
well-being, and life satisfaction.
It doesn't need to be grand gestures,
sometimes it can be the little things
that really make a difference.
Acknowledging somebody,
giving them eye contact, smiling,
opening a door, perhaps
picking up some litter
or making an environment
more comfortable for somebody,
or a compliment, can really help
to make a person's day glow.
There are many reasons why kindness
might have this positive effect.
It can boost our mood,
and acts of kindness can
help us feel more capable.
There is also some evidence
that it can help us buffer the
negative effects of stress.
Kindness is thought to be one
of the key ways that people create,
maintain, and strengthen
their social connections.
We're living in a world where we're
more connected than we've ever been.
But really positive connections
aren't just about
people who like you
on the internet,
it's about people who are going
to be with you for the good times
and for the bad times.
Making great connections in your life
is a little bit like building
sturdy bridges,
because they can help
to transport you safely
through challenging times
in your life.